all right so what is the most nutrient dense food
on the planet not plants organ meats organ meats
have 10 to 100 times more concentrated nutrients
than muscle meat you know like if you're going to
get a chicken breast or a steak or a hamburger
it has more bioavailable iron zinc selenium
vitamin a vitamin d b12 magnesium b1 b2 alpha
lipoic acid b6 phosphorus choline coenzyme q10
well certain types of organ meats like
the heart tissue for example and k2 okay
now here's the problem with plants there's no b12
there's no d3 there's no dha which is an omega-3
fatty acid you get the precursor which is ala
but you only convert a certain amount the other
problem with plants is that the vitamin a is in
the form of a pre-vitamin a and if you're going
to compare vitamin a it's really like 20 times
less of course they don't really tell you about
that they just say vitamin a but it's in the form
of beta-carotene the other problem with plants is
they have phytates which are anti-nutrients
so they block certain minerals like iron
calcium magnesium zinc so even though certain
vegetables might have more magnesium for example
the question is are they available to you now
the reason why i recommend plants for magnesium
and potassium because it's much easier to get
that nutrient because you would have to consume
i don't know 700 grams of animal meats to get the
same magnesium for example as you would seven cups
of vegetables so plants definitely are good
for certain things and this is of course
why you'd want to combine eating plants with
the animal products unless you have very severe
gut issues so now the question is what do
plants have that organ meats don't have well
they are loaded with something called
phytonutrients and phytonutrients have
some seriously amazing effects for your
health anti-inflammatory anti-cancer
anti-diabetic anti-microbial antiviral the list
goes on and on and on so phytonutrients give us
a lot of benefit with our health plants have
more vitamin k1 and i've already mentioned the
potassium and the magnesium so you would want to
combine them but realize that organ meats out of
all the foods have the most concentrated nutrients
in the most bioavailable source so personally even
though i know that i don't like to consume organ
meats i just don't like the taste so sometimes
i'll get them in supplements or i'll get them
hidden in hamburger for example u.s wellness meats
has various products various types of hamburger
that they blended in certain organ meats and the
one that i really like which i'll put a link down
below and by the way i don't get any kickbacks or
anything like that is the one with hamburger
with a little bit of heart meat which is
loaded with coenzyme q10 and i will say when
i consume that i do feel i have more endurance
so you might want to check that out hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled how
to bulletproof your immune system it's a free
course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today